our next guests are the reason we even
have that hit Netflix series Bridgeton
have you heard of it Shonda Rhimes
adapted the series for the screen from
the best-selling novels by Julia Quinn
now the two have written a new book
together Queen Charlotte is a name it's
a prequel to Bridgerton it follows a
young black German princess who marries
a white king of England their
interracial marriage transforms high
society and the book is based on the
scripts from rhyme's new Netflix series
Queen Charlotte a Bridgeton story we sat
down with Shonda and Julia last week and
this is our conversation
I want to start with you Shonda because
you have called Queen Charlotte the
Beyonce of Bridgerton yes why did you
want to tell her original story you know
she's so fantastic and fabulous and you
watch her and I was always really drawn
to her even from the first moment I saw
her on screen what do you think that
since Charlotte wasn't in your original
book series when you heard the idea that
she wanted to include it what did you
think I thought it was incredible and
then the way it turned out she was hands
down my favorite change to the series
she was she provided I think this
incredible framework for the story and
then the way that golden Rushville
portrayed her I mean she just owns the
screen whenever she's there she's just
fantastic how did you two work this out
together we talked about working
together and how that would be and then
because I'm a screenwriter who doesn't
ever write outlines or anything which is
very frustrating for people you don't
write outlines ever no I just write and
then things change as I'm writing and I
discover things while I'm writing so I
would write the scripts and send them to
her and she would turn them into
prose in this beautiful way it was
really each of us working with our area
of expertise but the story is so
fascinating because it's an interracial
couple back in the day and how they
transformed Society to bring in
diversity why did you think that was an
important story to tell well I mean that
we really wanted to explain how the
world of Bridgerton itself is populated
and in order to do that you know we say
their love United Society so we had to
go back and explore how that happened
and for me it was really gratifying to
tell the story of this young woman of
color coming in and clearly being
different part of the fun too for me
when when you watch it is the the
writing it always always starts with the
writing and then of course you have to
have great people who can deliver your
writing on the page and Golda who plays
Queen Charlotte never disappoints to me
Shonda I look at her lines some of my
favorites are you're lucky my face is a
rare Jewel or everything I do is a
blessing how do you see her as a
character
you know she's fascinating I mean gold
is an amazing actress she brings such
three-dimensionality to it but as a
character you know she's lonely yes well
Golda was here last week and of course
your name came up and this is what she
had to say
she is all about representation
inclusivity and I think we as artists as
people in the media have a platform that
we can celebrate those stories and we
can talk about those stories in a way
that maybe takes the pressure off a
little bit that's right to help people
lean in to help people be entertained
and then go out into the wider world and
discuss what they see yeah I'm not going
to write anything that doesn't reflect
me or that I can't see myself being a
part of it's one of the reasons why I
loved the Bridgeton books because even
though the characters were originally I
assume you're all right I could see
myself in those characters there was a
universality there and to be able to
bring that to the screen in a way that
was representative was exciting I assume
they were all white too weren't they all
white Juliet yeah I don't think I ever
said so but yeah I mean that's what I
was doing and I just have to say
my feeling toward Shonda land and
Netflix or the way that they have
brought the series to life my overwhelm
feeling is gratitude because they were
able to turn this world into a diverse
and inclusive World in ways that by
myself I didn't know how to do and and
again coming back to this what you can
do with film versus books
like for example if I'm going to write
the couple walking down the street I'm
not going to describe every person they
pass there's no reason to yes but if you
have a television show you've got these
people in the background and you don't
have to describe them because they're
there and you can just say this is the
world there's a writer's strike
Sean are you being affected by the
writer strike as we sit here today well
I'm a writer so I have a writer-led
company and it's very important to me
that nobody cross a picket line
um I'm a writer on strike so for the
next few months or however long it goes
I won't be putting pen to paper and I
think what's really hard are the people
who are doing this because they need to
make a living wage and so if they're
going to get to make a living wage then
I'm happy to be on strike and what do
you think it will take to resolve it I
honestly don't know I keep being
optimistic and saying maybe it'll only
be a few weeks but I don't I don't know
I'm hopeful we have to say
congratulations in order to Shonda
because as we sit here you've just
received a special bafta award that's a
British Academy of film and television
what does that mean to you it was such
an incredible honor to be there and I
felt a little overwhelmed when I when I
was there accepting the award it just
I don't think I'd ever dreamed of
anything in an international level and
it was it was a beautiful experience and
because you've had so many successes do
you feel pressure on yourself to
continue
no you don't I'm in this very lucky
space where I hit a moment
um
when I mean to continue to knock it out
of the park I know what I mean but I hit
this very special place where I was in a
moment where I could finally say okay
you can relax now everything else you do
is just for fun and so that's what I've
been doing wow wow Bravo and
congratulations Bravo Julia thank you
Queen Charlotte is on sale now wherever
you like to buy your books and by the
way Queen Charlotte the Netflix show
number one on Netflix you go Shonda